gather up your rail guns and crank up
your angsty teenage energy because today
we're covering something brand new sweet
huh I'm open to new things I guess I'm
talking about murder drones one of the
most popular animated series across all
of YouTube a series that has found a
completely different original way of
communicating its story to us instead of
using found footage or hidden shorts
videos to tell its story like most Indie
projects murder drones is releasing get
this 20 minute episodes one at a time in
sequential order what no QR codes no
unlisted videos Madness who knew that
structuring your animated series like an
actual animated series would feel so
refreshing these days
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that locked itself behind three
layers of doors to hide from the
watchful eye of the algorithm drones and
ladies and gentlemen today we're gonna
absolutely solve the world that is
murder drones produced by Glitch
entertainment here on YouTube Murder
drones tells the story of some teenage
robots who have to save the universe
from a rogue AI program and for as much
as I was just praising the series
earlier for its straightforward content
delivery strategy doesn't mean that the
story is a purely linear experience this
show is filled with twists flashbacks
and fourth wall breaks that keep you on
the edge of your seat guessing about
what's gonna happen next and that's not
an exaggeration either if you look away
for two seconds you stand to miss a
hidden detail or clue buried in
something as simple as flashing source
code or a class presentation which is
where I come in today since this is a
new series that I'd like to talk about
moving forward we are never talking
about this talking about what like I
said since this is a new show that I'd
like to talk about again sometime in the
future I want to start by giving you all
a simple straightforward overview of the
plot and key details that'll help you
fill in the gaps that you might have
missed during your first or even your
40th watch through I'm also going to be
doing it not in episode order but rather
timeline order the order that all the
major events actually happened in the
universe since that's the way that makes
the most sense as opposed to the twisty
way it's ultimately presented in the
show okay if I make a mistake along the
way just remember I messed up up in the
same way I'm about to fix it then by the
end of the episode today we'll actually
solve the rest of the first season
that's right we are six episodes in
right now six episodes spread across two
years so why wait any longer I suspect
that I know the big twist reveals that
are gonna be planned for the final two
episodes of the season and potentially
even deeper into the series and if you
don't want to be spoiled well I suppose
you could always just forget everything
that I say consider it uh repressed so
let's rewind or rather fast forward to
the three thousands as I introduce you
to a potentially new series and solve
where the murder drones universe is
headed next get hyped guys and yet I
still feel nothing
the main story of murder drones takes
place in the far future the year 3071 to
be exact based on these balloons that we
see in the background of episode 3's
prom scene however the real start to our
story happened quite a number of years
earlier this was a time when humans were
expanding beyond the confines of Earth
to set up colonies on planets outside of
our solar system mining them for all
their resources one of the biggest
players in this world was JC Jensen in
space to help with both Mining and
domestic life the company created a
series of autonomous AI robots called
worker drones each with their own
personality thoughts and feelings
basically these robots were
indistinguishable from a normal living
creature sadly though not everyone
agreed killing them for even perceived
minor offenses Western Villa style were
you programmed by beasts
pause it right there putting aside the
obvious issues around techno ethics here
that type of behavior right there is a
big No-No in the world of murder drones
you see all worker drones came packaged
with an established proper set of
step-by-step instructions for
decommissioning old robots and they're
delivered to us on old VHS tapes truly a
film theorist classic why should you
bother following those instructions well
simple drones May occasionally reboot
from software death alone more than
Undead Federal fine hazards
in short if improperly disposed of the
Dead robots might wake up literally
turning into zombie drones and not only
do they wake up they're changed in that
process according to the VHS these
drones experience quote potentially
hazardous mutations to their coding
which we later learned to be known as
the absolute solver program and that my
friends is why I always got to take time
to read the terms of service we're told
that there's only a .01 chance that the
robots will come back to life and of
that point zero one percent only point
seven percent have this dangerous
mutation thereby yielding a .007 chance
that the improperly disposed of drone
will have this absolute solver mutation
but of course this incredibly rare will
probably never happen thing in fact does
happen and it happens in the form of a
worker drone named sin waking up alone
confused and scared in a pile of robot
corpses she's eventually found by a
human girl named Tessa Elliott who's
taken a liking to some of the broken
worker drones and has been repurposing
them to be her friends among the drones
Tess has taken in are The Lovable goof n
the butt kicking V and the incredibly
loyal J the whole letter is a lot to
remember
but clearly sin is different the
absolute solver program that activated
inside of her changed her she speaks in
a more robotic Microsoft sam-esque voice
literally stating her emotions as they
happen and it generally seems that she's
on the fritz acting like a puppet on
strings sheepish nod giggle I am so
naughty however Tessa has a very
different view on the drones than her
parents parents who it would seem work
as higher at the J.C Jensen Corporation
well that's never directly stated in the
show we can infer it from what's said
during this moment when Tessa gets
locked up by her folks Sorry boss
corporate spoken Additionally the family
possesses an entire staff of worker
drones at their mansion on Earth
treating them more like slaves and pests
Tessa James Elliott
we will not entertain your dumpster pets
yeah yeah yes Mother sin infected by the
Hazardous mutation that is the absolute
solver program sees this and does not
like it eventually deciding that it
would be much better if these humans
just weren't around anymore and so when
The Elliots throw a big dinner party at
their mansion sin executes her plan
transforming into some Eldritch
Abomination and killing everyone at the
party except for Tessa the only human
who decided to treat this robot with
respect and sin didn't just stop at the
party she killed everyone on the planet
by collapsing the core of Earth we know
what mute damaged AI it took soon as a
host then it took everything and if you
thought killing off a planet's worth of
creatures would be enough think again
remember at this point in history humans
have expanded far beyond just one planet
meaning sin needed to find ways of
infiltrating these exoplanets if she
truly wanted to wipe Humanity from
existence thankfully for her humans ever
the Curious sponge did most of the heavy
lifting for her after seeing what
happened to Earth the humans brought
sins programming into their various
systems to study it and that was a big
mistake the absolute solver program does
the exact same thing again on copper
nine one of these human colonized
exoplanets and our main setting for the
series and again all human life gets
extinguished the newly liberated worker
drones now have no more commands that
they need to follow they are free to
live their lives as they wish and yet
this worker bot piece doesn't last for
very long at some point history a new
breed of drones did disassembly drones
or murder drones arrive on the scene
with a directive to eliminate all the
workers this forces the everyday Bots to
live behind a series of three protective
walls Attack on Titan style and though
the worker and murder drones are told
that this comes straight from the JC
Jensen Corporation we learn in episode 6
that that actually isn't the case
instead the murder drone massacres that
are happening across various planets are
being orchestrated by sin for unknown
reasons
[Music]
exoplanets why that's what we're trying
to figure out Bozo that's weird right
sin initially retaliated against humans
because of their callous mistreatment of
the worker drones but now she's sending
murder Bots out to Massacre the very
Bots that she initially worked to free
why well I suspect it's for recruitment
I suspect it's a numbers game if the
odds of the absolute silver mutation
activating in a dead drone is seven in a
hundred thousand you're gonna need to
pile up a whole lot of dead drones in
order to get a couple of absolute
solvers out of the group sin wants to
kill more and more worker drones not
because she's cruel but because she
wants to build her Army what's more the
absolute silver mutation seems to get
handed down between generations of robot
families which yes is a real thing in
this universe so Sid may just be looking
to speed up natural selection of this
super trait by weeding out all the
worker drones who don't possess it this
would basically be the concept of
robotic Eugenics get ready to clip this
next section out for your matpat out of
context compilations my friends but you
can't talk about murder drones without
talking about World War II during World
War II the Nazis firmly believed in
Eugenics eliminating quote unquote
undesirable genetic elements from the
German population so that the ideal
Aryan human could dominate in order to
create a race of genetically pure
physically fit human beings they use
tactics like forced sterilization and
selective breeding to ensure the
quote-unquote positive genes were the
more prevalent and circulated throughout
the gene pool by eliminating all the
normal worker drones it enables the
absolute solver code to dominate and
procreate for lack of a better term
beyond that though sin's motives remain
unclear is it to build up enough of an
army to fight against the last
strongholds of humanity is it because
she's lonely and she wants more like her
is it because app absolute solver has
actually been in control of her this
entire time currently it's unclear and
we're just gonna need more time to see
what happens anyway it's finally time
that we cut to the actual events of the
show yeah it is here finally where we
cut back to the story of our characters
as depicted in episode one Uzi our main
protagonist is one of the drones
unknowingly affected with absolute
solver having inherited it from her
mother Nori sadly Nori was killed by the
murder drones soon after uzi's birth and
now a teenager Uzi is full of rebellious
Teen Spirit annoyed that the workers
have hidden away from the murder drones
rather than fighting him head-on so
armed with a homemade railgun she
Ventures out of the safety of the doors
and meets n v and J Tessa's drone Army
that she rescued so many years ago and
now the murder drone Squad tasked with
slaughtering the workers of copper nine
except there's one problem with this by
the end of the episode uzi's absolute
solver has activated yes can't wait to
murder All Humans classic robot stuff I
hope they're sitting pretty there on
Earth cause we're coming for them as
we're getting this Cliffhanger ending
linked and you'll miss an important line
of code flashing on uzi's ivisor it says
absolute solver string equals false
before quickly switching over to true
yep our main protagonist now has herself
a penchant for human genocide which
again feels weird since Uzi didn't die
here how could the absolute solver
program have activated inside of her if
she needs to have been a zombie bot for
it to have activated well remember the
code for these drones functions a lot
like DNA meaning that their programming
can be handed down between Generations
it seems that Nori the mother of Uzi
passed it down to her daughter in the
same way that human parents pass down
hair color or some other disease or
trait and when passed down this way
absolute sulfur doesn't require death to
activate so Uzi teams up with the
disassembly drones to solve the mystery
of what's actually going on looking for
Clues around Copper 9 eventually leads
the gang to a place called Cabin Fever
Labs an old JC Jensen facility this
place is filled with a lot of
interesting details for one the show
makes it Canon that despite killing all
humans on Earth the doggos are in fact
alive safe and Immortal see sometimes a
plot can be a great thing also at this
place we get ourselves a tiny hint about
a new character as uzi's exploring the
cabin fever Labs she picks up some
paperwork that talks about
decommissioning a particular worker
drone named
s010011x01 we don't get an official name
for the Drone but based on the way that
this series turns serial numbers and
names the fans have dubbed this
character s You could argue that this is
just a random sheet of paper but I don't
think so this clue about an S drone
happens in the same episode where we
learn about the insane things that uzi's
Mom used to say before she went full
absolute solver
she was always all build doors against
the coming Sky demons
look at this cool ass I can draw Sky
demons Singularity cool s more s things
I believe this s character will be
making their appearance sometime in the
seventh episode of the series as a good
robot built by Tessa to make some big
reveal about uzi's mom's death you see
in this series every drone has two
numbers that ultimately identify them
one is their SN or serial number a
string of letters and numbers unique to
each character the second number is the
PN presumably the product number this
string indicates what model of drone
they are drones that are the same kind
have the same pns we see that this is
true with n and J and presumably V who
all have themselves the same PN sin m y
k x notice that Cyn or sin hidden right
there all the murder drones are part of
the same sin model group and have been
controlled by sin at some point
throughout the series however this s has
itself a completely new PN that we
haven't seen before TSA m m a c now the
TSA there can't be a coincidence when we
have ourselves a human named Tessa
running around who loves repairing
robots and is trying to stop quest of
absolute domination in addition I
believe we'll discover that s was a
friend or colleague of uzi's mother Nori
how can I be sure well in episode 3
where show Nori's security badge which
shows that she used to work at Cabin
Fever Labs the same is true for Eva
another carrier of the absolute solver
corruption and wouldn't you know it but
Cabin Fever Labs is the same place that
Uzi found the document about s
furthermore take a closer look at that
document we see black creepy drawings
written all over it these drawings bear
a striking resemblance to the ones that
were drawn by uzi's mother so I think at
this point it's far more likely that
whoever this s character is will be an
old Ally of norian Eva and will be
willing to lend a hand to Uzi and
Company as they try to defeat the
absolute solver corruption moving back
into the main story though for a minute
after exploring around Cabin Fever Labs
Uzi starts to act strange and we begin
to see the full extent of her absolute
solver Powers she transforms into some
kind of monster and attacks all the
other drones after being talked down by
n Uzi returns to normal solidifying them
as the cutest couple ever eventually the
team finds a key in the form of a
robotic Cricket that unlocks the
innermost part of Cabin Fever labs they
then run into Tessa Elliott the girl who
befriended sin and the other drones back
in the day Tessa now an adult has made
it her mission to stop sin and any other
absolute solver drones from taking over
the universe in the end of the most
recent episode we see Uzi and in Tessa
finding their way to the elevator that
leads down into the innermost lab
leaving them and us the audience curious
about what they'll discover down there
and honestly that's where the series
stands at the end of episode 6. the
creators of the show have said that the
first season will consist of Eight
Episodes we're really close to the end
and there's still a lot of mysteries
that have yet to be solved is Uzi gonna
fully transform into sin is this
mysterious s character gonna make an
appearance will Tessa be forced to kill
Uzi to save the world well loyal
theorists it turns out you don't have to
wait for the next four to six months for
the final episodes to come out I suspect
that I already know everything that's
gonna happen there beat for beat in the
final two episodes in fact I suspect
that we've known where the show was
headed since the very first scene of the
very first episode right after the
opening exposition of episode 1 the show
reveals everything to us right when
we're first introduced Uzi she's given a
power PowerPoint presentation to our
class about the dangers of sitting
around waiting for the murder drones to
find a way past the doors
I don't drink ice behind three stupid
doors
the Graham appears behind her this image
is almost a complete rip of the infamous
hero's journey if you're not familiar
with that the hero's journey is a
storytelling template that many of the
stories throughout history have followed
from ancient epics like Gilgamesh and
the Odyssey to Modern Classics like
Harry Potter and Star Wars if you're
writing yourself a Fantastical story
then the hero's journey is breaking down
the format of your narrative now on my
first viewing I saw this references just
that a reference murder drones loves
meta humor in fourth wall break so I
just chalked this up to another inside
joke however when I went back to the
series again in preparation for this
Theory I realized that everything that's
happened in the first six episodes has
lined up exactly with this little visual
gag beat for beat we start off with the
call to action that draws the hero into
Adventure Uzi wants to leave the safety
of the doors and deal with the murder
drones directly then she gets saved by
an unlikely Aid and right after this Uzi
teams up with helper Dal and a mentor
who's been around the block Tessa
together this crew fights back against a
bunch of challenges and Uzi becomes more
and more tempted to use the absolute
solver abilities culminating with her
being fully possessed by sin and N
having to cut off her hand in episode 6.
and mind you this diagram isn't just for
any generic hero's journey it is one
that is specifically built for Uzi
notice all the references to angst
moments built into this wheel and if
there is one emotion that definitely
connects back to Uzi it is angst an
angsty teen fad bite me and I made you
Rebel like an angsty teen which got you
killed so if I'm right that then leaves
us right here on the chart at the bottom
ready for another Helper and a big
Revelation that's tied to three specific
things rebirth abyss and death so remind
me again where these characters are
exploring Cabin Fever Labs a giant
underground facility that keeps going
down to the center point and Abyss if
you will and who have we been talking
about this entire time s a potential new
helper associated with uzi's dead mom
probably has more information than
anyone about what happened to her
according to the hero's journey at this
point Uzi our hero will be given some
sort of a revelation s is gonna reveal
some Saucy detail something that
according to our template will lead Uzi
to a full angst overload if what we've
seen previously are just tiny overloads
what could this possibly look like what
could be so devastating for Uzi to hear
that it'll send her into a presumed
meltdown well I suspect that s is gonna
reveal that n was the murder drone who
killed uzi's mom yeah I'm just as
shocked as you are but n is the most
likely killer at this point in the
series we don't actually know what
happened to Nori all we know was that
she was bitten by some murder drone that
Nori's father ultimately had to put her
down on copper 9 there's only three
murder drones that we know of the J and
of course n nothing would make for a
more catastrophic Revelation than
finding out your new boyfriend is the
one that killed your mom this
devastating news will be too much for
Uzi to handle and she'll fully succumb
to her absolute solver Powers going full
angst overload then after being saved
once again by Anne and the crew Uzi will
atone for her sins and make her mission
for season two clear defeat sin stop the
absolute solver and end the cycle of
violence that prevents humans and drones
from living the peaceful lives they want
so there you have it my friends murder
drones the plot so far as well as a
solid hypothesis or two and where might
be headed in the final episodes of the
Season how am I so sure about this I
guess you could say it's a mixture of
Easter eggs narrative logic and a whole
lot of watching other forms of media you
know stuff like movies TV shows and of
course anime oh and they said pirating
all that anime was useless but hey
that's just a theory a film Theory and
cuts
[Music]